voici ce qui se passe lors d'un accident
d'autobus scolaires lorsque les enfants
ne sont pas attachés et voici ce qui
pourrait se passer si les élèves étaient
attachés au canada les ceintures sont
obligatoires dans les voitures depuis 43
ans
l'immense majorité des élèves sont
transportés dans des autobus sans
ceinture comme celui ci je vais la
voiture a les yeux bleus arrivés rentrer
dans l'autobus littéralement à
mont-saint-hilaire en 2016
l'autobus de virginie riel et gabriel
gélinas s'est renversée sous la force
d'un impact latéral à haute vitesse
virginie a été projeté de haut en bas
directement sur les fenêtres
j'avais une lacération environ 5 cm puis
ça ça pissait le sang
j'avais une comme sont sévères après une
commotion cérébrale vous qu'on a basculé
sur le côté si nous étions attachés on
aurait évité une trogne de blessure pour
gabriel les ceintures sont nécessaires
mais pas pour transports canada qui
considère que les enfants sont
suffisamment protégés par ses hôtes
banquette coussiné transports canada se
base sur sa propre étude qui fait
autorité en la matière depuis 35 ans
mais qui ne tient pas compte des
accidents les plus graves comme les
tonneaux et les impacts latéraux
une autre étude de transports canada
beaucoup plus récente reconnaît que les
ceintures à bandoulière comme celles ci
sont plus sécuritaires
mais cette étude là a été tenue secrète
jusqu'à ce que nos collègues de siby si
la découvre évidemment rendre les
ceintures obligatoire pourrait entraîner
une augmentation du coût des autobus
d'environ 10%
c'est bien ce qui inquiète les
transporteurs scolaires il y aura une
marge de profit à ce moment là il est
peut-être des entreprises qui risquent
d'être occultées financière le fédéral
pourrait imposer la ceinture mais le
ministre garneau marche sur des oeufs
on veut discuter avec les provinces par
exemple d'abord lieu des coûts
additionnels deuxièmement si on veut
s'assurer que tous les enfants soient
bien attachés si on utilise des
ceintures de sécurité
c'est quelque chose qui est assez
complexe complexe mais urgent ajoute le
ministre qui a demandé à transports
canada de refaire à nouveau ses devoirs